going I'm not going to lie I've been
kind of out of it
lately did a whole bunch of stuff on
algorithms last week and now I'm just
trying to get back into the swing of
things I think really the main thing was
just the
the amount of mental effort that went
into uh the generalized Advantage
estimation work on the theory side not
even really Theory it's not even that
hard of math but it was a little bit
unintuitive uh I think I have something
though that will work so really my goal
for today is just to get something
implemented
there and
um I'm hoping that we can get something
training is the X streaming working
again it is
works okay so we are on the right
branch and I think that all I want
wanted to
yeah I'm going to make gamma sum I
thought about this a little for a little
while off stream actually it's not even
gamma sum it's gamma Max that I want to
be normalize by this was the
do if gamma is greater than gamma Max we
update gamma Max
been busy it's not even as much as I've
been busy as much as um just last week
was pretty mentally taxing with the type
of work that I was doing
it you know you know when you're like
really out of it and your brain just
won't do what you want
yeah but um I think that I good enough
here to at least get in enough to finish
this algorithm and then we'll be able to
move on to other stuff like your tweet
from hours ago which
one the
uh anthropic one or the other
stuff I don't know what it is where like
oh yeah I don't know where what it is
with these Labs right they have all
these technical people doing awesome
work and then like for absolutely no
reason what whatever like the CEOs just
decided to be total scumbags and lie
about everything I mean hell even the
name of the [ __ ] company it's not
anthropic AI it's not you guys are
Contracting with paler uh for defense
Tech which is fine defense is good but
don't call yourself anthropic and say
we're going to be a city on the hill for
how people should do AI development like
[ __ ]
off they want the Manhattan Project
contract and I don't trust them with it
because they lie and they virtue signal
and they say that they're holier than
that thou and they're
right there's almost nobody I trust less
than a highly ethical SF Tech bro
they can't stop yeah
exactly and if they try we will fight
back
okay um this is a little tricky here
because this requires
I think this requires two passes doesn't
it that
okay I don't use this yet do
I go
gamma the thing is I don't want to be
fighting them either like I would like
them to just [ __ ] off and let me do my
stuff
right might be moving to Austin my
friend doesn't get a new role after the
reorg 100K Capital to get going bring
around 200k if it goes well postto is
not worth it if he can join the team
awesome best of luck with
that that sounds
great I haven't ever been to Austin I
don't think Texas is cool I don't think
I've been to Austin
more that's what uh you're looking at
Captain I want to actually make some
progress here I don't want to just sck
around and like keep being confused
here tenture for future collab if it
happens great really career-minded
called me two days
ago awesome
well I mean good luck with that
right you let me know when you need RL
stuff if it's promising right puffer
takes uh for startups puffer takes
Equity over
cash so you can get uh some help on
stuff without having to burn any
Runway but that's only if you actually
have an RL problem set up that I think
is like reasonable right I'm not going
to waste your time on stuff if there's
not like a clear-cut RL
setup wa what I haven't gotten an email
back
yeah we discussed that yep I know I'm
just bringing it up favorable in all
situation easier to jump out of yeah
just make sure they're actually on for
the ride
right I had a whole course at uh MIT
that was literally just dealing with
co-founder [ __ ] and I was like you
know what I think I'm happier doing this
[ __ ] solo anyways
well that's me a lot of people do very
well co-founded and it makes it easier
to raise
Capital much easier to raise Capital
with multiple people on board I don't
know why it's kind of funny it works
that
way but I wasn't going that route
anyways raising Capital kind of
hello hello
welcome we're working on the advantage
kernel for the new algorithm right
now um I think I figured out a really
simple way to deal with the
normalization crap that was messing with
me we're just going to divide gamma by
the maximum gamma uh and we're going to
hope that works
Chevron in school they'd be sad to lose
him hope they do for my sake
gee why you know if you piss off your
people
right big companies are just a rough
place to work a lot of the
time as far as I'm
concerned it's like stable but that's
about it
finally fixed a small bug and impulse
Force that's been plaguing me for a
month made a few more small tweaks
really fun to play even against script
AG
awesome hey looks like there'll be a PR
on that
soon working at smaller places much more
yeah I don't think I've ever
been I don't think I've ever been more
depressed than when I was like at Amazon
for a summer and it wasn't the fault of
you know the guy that brought me on he
was actually like trying to make
progress there were a few other people
that were trying to make progress but
then there were just like a ton of
people who were just like shipping
thousands of lines of garbage code that
you'd have to deal with and were like
clearcut clearcut 9o5 vers which it's
like you never like they never wanted to
do any extra work on anything to make
something you know actually functional
they'd like get mad if you off railed
their like very bureaucratic worthless
meeting to try to like discuss a new way
of doing stuff it was just like I never
want to deal with these type of people
again right this is a waste of my
time way more interesting to be working
with people who give a
that PO Advantage normal Advantage
normalization this is
p3o Advantage normalization this is the
new algorithm that I'm working
so where does it get this reward from
though is the
1 I don't
understand how this has
nonzero reward
odd I want to make sure we have this
kernel implement correctly and then
actually properly test it today instead
of like fiddling around with stuff
that's probably half
wrong yeah under no circumstance should
this be able to be positive
right oh hang on
wait no buff
has reward
R which is gamma time r r is rewards t +
1 which should be
Zero DS there's no nothing is
done okay so this is very
odd why would it be like this
Colonel this is a Cuda colel
docu isn't that what you call them
anything in Cuda for like uh just a
little math op it's a Cuda kernel
Cuda oh yeah hey uh hey Captain you
might have
this might be a little crazy but I think
I think I came up with a way to run uh a
lot of our environments uh in Cuda
without changing the
least so this is a crazy idea right um
this is honestly like kind I think it's
kind of Genius
but
um this is just C right and it just has
an index operation where it just gives
it the index on which to run the
code okay so we'll just make this index
the index of the current environment and
then just call the environment code and
then it'll be Cuda parallel right with
each Cuda core on a different
environment instead of running them
serly on the same core on the CPU
it's pretty funny
right like doesn't that actually kind of
work so I think it would be pretty funny
if after all this time of writing all
these M's right we actually came up with
a way to just run them in Cuda for the
hell of
it so I might play with that at some
point when I next get some
time cuz sometimes I don't know this is
like the something that occurred to me
while I was running I was
like we're g to run the environment on
Cuda and we're going to call it
Barracuda you just compile it with Cuda
compiler
yep it's kind of funny isn't it I get
cool ideas every once in a while usually
I don't have that many good ideas but
every once in a while
I just think it would be hilarious to
Just Like H with the Jack people this on
the GPU and there's no overhead of the
transfer it's like okay we changed the
compile settings and now we run on GPU
and our code seem easier to
read GP would be doing everything yeah
so the idea would be it would have to be
so so so fast right that like you don't
even notice the overhead but I just
think it would be funny
regardless and also it would kind of
like open it up a little bit for us
right like let's say we wanted to really
do some heavy physics environments right
we could just write the whole thing and
see and then you know maybe some little
things need to run in Cuda who knows
or maybe we just like ah whatever we
prototype it on the CPU and then we just
paste it to the GPU and it's
right I mean cud is just C like look at
this this is C you could paste the same
code into C with just this index and it
would
run it's a would it speed up impulse
Wars maybe maybe
I mean I wouldn't go into this for
impulse Wars initially right I would try
this on something silly but um it's a
it's a
possibility main thing I want to do is I
want to get you finished up with impulse
Force you can help me on Research side
stuff CU I need help on research and I
need to train some more researchers to
help me
yeah it's kind of cool to see
like how quickly people are learning um
you know through puffer lib how quickly
people are getting good at uh at puffer
stuff like I mean Spencer's been what
here for several months maybe like at
this point and honestly like Dev side I
think he can already do more in RL like
than the vast majority of
phds um so if you come in with strong
programming background I'm sure you'll
be the same I just haven't reviewed your
code yet to be able to make that
assertion right but um yeah pretty much
if you just come into RL with a strong
programming background and you really do
the lowlevel stuff and then you kind of
like on board the rest of it you're
really already doing more than the
majority of
people all right what I got to focus up
on this what is wrong
here like
seriously do I bite the bullet and just
write a
test the only thing is I don't know
how how do you write a test for this
when it's running through P
torch can I just can I run this without
Pi
bind what you think of impulse Wars long
review yeah that's fine hey if you put
the effort into an uh to write a long
environment I do a long
review see shortcuts and simulating the
physics yeah so that's where we need
that's tough because there you need
people who are like really good lowlevel
programmers and good at physics like I
probably wouldn't be able to see how to
do that cuz I don't understand the
physics that's the tough
bit I mean physics at the level of
Robotics yeah I might be able to see
some shortcuts but uh like physics
physics no that's harder
this since I don't know how to write a
test for
this I am going to leverage uh I'm going
to get Gro to do a little bit but then
I'm going to clean it up substantially
I really don't like doing this type of
thing at
all let's see do we have people yelling
me no I have people yelling at the
people yelling at me
great how to get good at low level just
do it write some M's in
puffer the stuff we're doing in puffer
is really not that complicated like
honestly like compared to like some like
really close embedded system stuff like
close to Hardware embedded system stuff
we're really just doing basic
C keeping it very
simple and integrating stuff nicely with
the rest of our RL tools it's not that
hard it's really not that hard I promise
you
to give you an idea though of how easy
it is
uh I wrote python for 10 years and I was
comfortable in C in 3
weeks how to get started literally just
like build a little end look
here this is the simplest possible demo
I can give you right we have from very
simple to very complex right
ocean here squared very B basic little n
square. okay here's some boiler plate
that does memory
allocations here's the logic that's
it what is what do you need to be able
to do this right you need to know the
difference between a value and a
reference that's just what a pointer is
right you need to be able to write if
statements and maybe write Some Loops
that's
it like any first year undergrad who has
taken like their first systems course
can do this
if they actually bother to like
try Okay and then from here you know you
go onto something like
pong I don't know how clean the pong
code is to be fair maybe snake is better
I did
snake Okay 300 lines there's some
logging here's the
code what does it have a few Loops some
conditionals
single pointers that's it snake is so
good for multi-agent inspiration yeah
it's I hope it is and I wrote I think I
cleaned this code a little bit up since
I wrote it but I basically wrote this
after having been programming in c for a
couple of weeks it's not hard it's
really not hard you just have to
actually try like you just have to start
you just have to set aside some time you
have to care enough to actually you know
put in the effort to learn and like you
know understand that it is a good thing
to go lower
level for a long time that was the
mental block for me is I didn't want to
get lower level because I Associated it
with like buggier code slower pace of
development right and it's literally
just skill issue like it's just straight
skill issue like as soon as you start
doing it and then you learn a little bit
you realize like oh I can compile my
code with f sanitize then I don't get
seg puls I get reasonable error messages
oh no I have to think about memory
allocation and deallocation oh wait
that's really really easy you do your
allocations you run your code you delete
the allocations that's it okay oh I have
to think about pointers it's just a
reference okay oh but double pointers
are hard like I have to think about
multiple layers of interaction don't use
them 1D indexing is so hard it's like
you don't have like multiple sliced
syntax okay
uh you make a little function X Y with *
x + y or what with time y + x there
that's your 1D indexing
done that's it there's nothing else hard
here it's just like we put stuff up on
so much of a
okay
uh I hate how it's written this test
I think what I'm going to do is instead
of having this clean it up I'm going to
clean it up manually so that I learn
more are llms good so I can maybe get
started yes but I don't suggest that you
have them just generate your code for
you because they generate crappy code
and you don't learn much that way like
what I suggest you do instead is you
start with one of the reference projects
so copy that as a template go through
and understand it try to build your
environment from there and then use the
LS the llm is docks like ask it
questions when you're
confused as I paste a giant block of
code but I'm about to clean this crap up
because this code
sucks
um I might at least run it first
though for
it also it depends on your programming
background right like did you do well I
don't know where you are in life right
but if you did an undergraduate course
in C ever at one point you know
enough just go through squared and try
to understand what it is what and how
yeah I mean really the only con Concepts
like do you know what a pointer is yeah
rebuild it like you can make your own
little end right comes with rendering
it's really easy to hack on you learn
from
there the only like you should know what
a pointer is
right you should know basic programming
loops and conditionals you should know
what a struct is like I don't know your
background right but like the PRX are
very low the bar is very very low for
only thing I'm not familiar with is meem
Alec okay you need a piece of memory you
need some number of bytes of memory so
you call Malik of that many bytes and
now you have
memory you just get a pointer you just
get the address and memory of where
you're going to write your data it shows
you in in the example as as well how
I've done that because we don't do that
at all once you've made the environment
you allocate the memory that you need
for your environment you run your
environment using that memory and then
you just clean it up at the end that's
oh that is so
funny look at
that it literally can't even do this
basic test
work passing in incompatible pointer
type in definition of macro I don't know
why it made this macro anyways it's a
useless macro we'll do this one
here hello how are things today they're
going working on some stuff
what does Cuda Malik
take
calic neural net how I did copy squared
zero experience in see red basic stuff
yep I generally suggest that new people
learning stuff like you spend 80% of
your time building you spend 20% of your
time seeking out and learning from
resources also it is a void star
star Dev
pointer pointer to allocated device
take change M
malic no we wouldn't would
we I I think all we would do is just
like we just we Malik in the init right
you just change those to Cuda malic and
I think you're done so you just make a
Cuda version of the init
function it's like a tiny amount of
code memory with the dev
pointer I don't know what this is I've
never used
see it's analogous to
Malik Al is GPU
memory a pointer to a pointer that will
be set to the address of the allocated
device
memory if you want to void Star Pass in
void star star so the function can
set I don't I don't know why it doesn't
just give me a pointer
back function arguments are pass by
value P Malik were designed to take a
void
star well that's not what I asked dummy
why would it need a void star in the
first place is this thing gaslighting me
T oh I see because don't want to return
the pointer that's
obnoxious
um I thought you can just check the
value of the pointer though if it
doesn't give you a proper pointer
no I don't want to wrap it I want to
understand what the heck this
is okay
so you just give
it okay so you just make the pointer
yeah that's not bad though because you
don't actually deal with the double
pointer you just give it the address of
the pointer and the pointer is populated
for you
% yes my I'm my yes that was done wait
no because it's not that it's then you
have to do void star star can you even
cast that
way is that even a valid cast
guess it is okay I wouldn't think that
would be a valid cast because that's a
float star star to avoid star I didn't
know you could do that a double cast
like that
though I don't like being made to deal
with double pointers for no
reason well this isn't C being gross
right this is specifically Cuda Malik
being
SE well yeah but like every language has
a bunch of stupid API
standard for
[Music]
C how many thread blocks
okay so this can't be in a DOT
what are your thoughts on the Alberta
plan haven't seen it I use a rest real
quick I'll be right
back
right undefined reference to did I get
the signature
wrong W block mask values mean
deviation buff DS rewards advantages
bounds
sub probably the inclusion is
wrong
include try
this
ah okay how do you do that
then I guess uh you have to set
separate what you do
is s that suton helped
develop i' have to read it
um now obviously I give Su tremendous
tremendous credit for his contributions
in the earlier days of RL I don't know
about his latest research directions and
what he's doing um so I'd have to
look PR from Branch merge into local
Fork what are you
pring it depends what you're pring if
you're pring like a critical bug fix or
something that needs to be in main
immediately then it goes to 2 but if
you're pring a new end yeah it should
probably go into Dev um I mean if you
have something that you want to be like
immediately included into main that's
like stable and doesn't have any weird
build issues and stuff like that then I
can try to get it into main faster um
but if there any like questions about
stuff you know and maybe needing a
little bit more work then it goes to
Dev yeah Brad I'd have to look at it and
I really want to get this done right now
so I think like chatting about whatever
else is on in here is about the most I'm
not going to like just go read this
right
now might need more work yeah then just
go to
death go to Dev I generally suggest new
people like you know try to to uh like
try to come up with like simple
environments that are an interesting
learning problem in some way I don't
know if this is uh an environment that I
gave you the idea for if you're just
coming up with one on your own but know
either
way two just
Dev yeah I have everything in just Dev
right
now I need to do a big cleanup of a lot
of the branches at some point soon
okay so I think that this is how we do
this right so we
do puffer lib
we we go
here we grab the pi
check so now we can do our test and our
torch separately and we have a nice
puffer lip file to import everything
from
I'm probably missing something about why
this check was there in the first place
but I didn't like that it made a macro
this num steps will
be
16 what was it 32
step Horizon is
16 step The Horizon of eight is
here it's kind of silly that we pass
value mean isn't
I think you can
do if I do this I can use this for
static allocation can't I
particularly if I just I put
these up top
deviation going through but B and Sutton
book I think
C and ocean
M's would be nice to have I gotta be
honest with you I've never read that
book I probably should have and at some
point you know I will probably get
bitten and have to go back and like I
don't know do a treat for a month in
which I just try to actually understand
RL math
um but if you're trying to get into RL
and you're trying to get some stuff to
work uh quickly then there is much more
math in that book than you need to be
productive um if you like coming at
things from a math angle then it's a
perfectly good resource if you want a
more engineering oriented reference that
still references uh like good lit good
lit to learn from
I would suggest my quick start
issues when merging with Dev
Branch I try to run the demo file with
my
m i get an
arrow comes from the Pyro module
annoying uh
I I don't know why you would get an
install error on that so pyro is a
gaussian it's used for G processes and
we need it in our new sweeps Library do
you have like a really old version of
torch or
install 251 I think that should be
fine I assume you don't mean 3.1 I
assume you mean 3.10 or 3.11 or
something I don't know why that would
crash you're free to comment it out
though
r0 you're free to just comment out that
there's only it's only used in one place
in uh sweeps so you're free to just
comment it
out pip name isn't pyro oh pyro PPL okay
yeah careful you know people name squat
packages and some of them are
malicious people will like put malware
into um packages with similar names to
uh to Common packages so you got to be a
little careful
guessing yeah there you
go there you
go okay lovely now we have this test set
up and we just have to figure out
uh we just have to figure out what's
wrong with it
but look how clean this is now can I run
this with Cuda GDB is the
Advantage any
docu yeah but again just just comment it
okay there's a reason that the dev
branch is a Dev Branch right it's
because I'm like I'm adding and changing
stuff in it
constantly so all you have to do is find
like you're allowed to just comment [ __ ]
out all you have to do and just don't
add the comments to your PR right all
you have to do is make sure that the N
works on like some version minus
whatever stuff I'm I'm working on and
I'll merge it in no no worries like this
is just me hacking on stuff right like
yeah that Cuda module absolutely doesn't
need to be imported at the top of the
file right and there should be a
fallback I just haven't done it yet
why do it not hit my break
point e
why does it not give
me how do I set break points in this
then
train uh the Environ the requirement is
just to make sure that the N works
correctly but uh if it won't
train then the M wait why won't it
train it should I think the uh that do
like that so that Cuda function should
only be required for P30 which is not
the
default so I think it should train with
po still
puffero does uh did the environment
train before on your setup though like
did you get the environment training on
uh on your
setup oh what uh can you remind me what
environment this
multi- grid agents need to manage food
and not deplete okay
ah
that's
why that's so cool we can uh we have
debugging through Cuda
now so basically Cuda is just C we just
write C you compile a little differently
that's
it same debug as before pretty
much and uh things are just
easy that's really
nice I mean that was the one annoying
thing before is just not having the
debugger right and it's the thing that
sucks about cython is not really having
a good
abilities but the thing is it's like not
even hard it's just easy
go so we'll figure out why
uh why it just worked this way
I don't know don't like I think like C
and Cuda are like these super scary
things to a lot of people I thought Cuda
was going to be way worse than this but
like this is really
chill this is just this is just easy
it's like a yeah the hardcore the
hardcore Cuda and come on you're writing
C you're writing C and then thinking
maybe you're thinking you know over
parallelism in multiple Dimensions or
blocks or whatever who
cares yeah you might be solving hard
problems with it but like the language
isn't
can probably use conditional
compilation to make ocean M's
build um I don't know why you would do
that though
right why would you do that when you can
just Define two different init methods
or
whatever
right and and you can just use the Cuda
method like the Cuda init method in the
Cuda
version then you don't even need
conditional
yeah but
like you would just make like I did with
the test file
right so in the test file you just make
Cuda in it and you just when you
initialize your environment you just use
that one instead of regular in
right have to play with it of course but
it doesn't seem that
bad I am thinking about the scon layer
though and it's I'm not happy about that
scon layer at
I think you could do the same thing with
a function and then
yes I'd say do it with a function not a
macro oh wait does it have to be
defined I might have to look at
that macros just get I do not like
macros I'm not a macros enjoyer
h
yeah I just found a bug with this
debugger that I would have not I
wouldn't have never found that bug
I will see the necessity when I get
there
lovely now we actually get to see what
is
useful we can ensure that our kernel
actually gives us the advantage that we
like and then without changing the code
we should just be able to uh have this
bound to P torch
with hoer li. CU just like this just
Imports this separately adds the torch
dependency
right that should
work let me see if I like the way that
it's done the reward
computation so we
do 1 two 3 4
two wait
one one and then
two we get a gamma of
one reward of one
reward is
zero gamma
R is
one did I forget something
here oh you do have a second reward here
silly yeah you're
good okay
so you go one step before this is
one and then another
right so you see the reward
here you get one and then you have one
and then you see the reward here and you
get two so you have two
okay and then the second
one you get one and one
yeah because you start on this
step then you get one and
zeros and then if you keep going a
little
right if I'm
done I grab the reward from the next
time
step
right or
no no if you're done you grab the reward
from this time step
how do I have it right
now duns of te
here no so we'll have to figure out this
indexing but this is so much easier now
having just have having a debugger this
no longer feels painful this process
this whole thing felt like very annoying
and painful without the debugger and now
it feels just like I mean I could just
be writing normal C right I could just
you know be writing not Cuda and it's
the same thing so this is great be right
back give me a second and then we will
finish debugging this thing and uh we'll
make some decisions and we'll be able to
actually run experiments hope this is
great get
let's figure out the actual indexing
that we need to do
signal uh that is the same step you get
the last reward on right
looks
yeah
I think this looks good to
me
so
211 that's a correct
sum and then you lose the last reward
right so you just
get how do you lose the last reward no
you don't lose the last reward you lose
the
you lose the first
reward yes you lose the first reward and
you get one and one and then you go
ahead of step and then you get
one and then you go ahead of step and
then you hit the episode bound and you
get one and one and then you go ahead
one you get one and then you hit the end
of the episode all the episodes this is
correct
great this is hopefully a correct fernel
so advantage
konel
P that would be a little too much to
hope for that it works instant instantly
and this one's offset one further back
so this is
perfect Yep this is absolutely perfect
is there a way to see
where the illegal access
is oh you know
here let me just try one thing real
quick oh no I don't have done here at
the end I was thinking like hey maybe if
there's a done at the end it's like
capping
it but this should be fine
I check everywhere I have a division
don't
yeah I'm not seeing where this would be
uh an illegal
access Sy yeah it's right after this as
well isn't it
this did not get us any better
information did
it can I pass this to the the compile
flag or
error yeah that's just going to say
whether it's in
um which kernel uh whether it's what
level it's
at exact line
okay hang on can we
do Huda M check
is removed and has been replaced with
compute sanitizer
run how do I run this with
python worst part ofuda Dev how to get
it how to run it's actually only because
I'm running it through uh pytorch and I
don't get the error uh without running
it through P torch we have this has been
actually really nice so this is the Cuda
kernel
here and we have this test right here
and this works we caught several bugs
with this and then here's the binding
just the pi bind now the only thing
that's wrong
here is um I I get an error running
through torch that's not caught by the
test and I want the trace right like I
basically want to just compile it with a
sanitizer and I can't figure out how to
do that
you shouldn't need to ex include this in
the
this I don't know if this will work
because I don't think you have symbols
here oh jeez and now this is running the
compute sanitizer on everything
want do we only
apply s
uous reward block mean standard
deviation buff done
forwards this
failure pbind would catch like wrong
type stuff wouldn't it
see I don't see how this could possibly
be
um a launch error
though right like how could this
possibly be a launch error
yeah you see that's
fine I wonder if this does it
I gota be doing something stupid here
right I don't see anything though
so it just gas lights you
huh useless
bot right here Colonel name
error building did I mess something up
here
so
weird debugging definitely needs to be
better
here and to be clear it builds without
this
valid values for Keys kernel
name kernel
so I don't even know if this is a build
error with uh running this through torch
or
what so that's
obnoxious I mean I could just try to
find it I think longer term though I'm
going to want better debugging Tools in
this
31 so this could be
31 and
then wrote. H file for
there is a h file for squared right I
mean did you do something based on it
right c. Pi what about pix oh I think
okay you're trying to learn learn this
stuff so um if you just look at the I
mean either in 20 or Dev it's the same
thing if you just look at this directory
right you'll see how we do all the
bindings for everything so here's the
scon file we're currently using as the
intermediary it's a short little file
and it just defines the intermediate
functions as well as the loop over
multiple
copies hang on I think I do I think I'm
still off by one
here right because if this goes up to
here so we write
in we write in this manner right
um yeah it's it's meant to be an example
right so like all that squared is it's a
really simple environment to use as an
example to get yourself familiar with
the process of writing efficient
environment code and then binding it to
python so you can actually use it for RL
right so we have the C files you can
just run this whole thing in pure C this
is nice for development and we also use
it for
demos right you have theh which has the
actual logic everything in
see the scon file which is just
essentially The Binding layer
and then finally you get to see how you
use it in oops not this one you get to
see how you use it in
Python and I mean we have examples like
this for everything I mean all the all
the different environments serve as
examples so if you like write something
based on squared you get comfortable
then you can look at something like
snake for a slightly more complex
example it's only like I don't know 300
some odd lines of code and a lot of it's
just the logging that we add in and
here's the uh the end code right here's
the code for computing observations
removing snakes adding snakes creating
food here's the reset function here's
the game
logic 100 lines and there you
go oh did I still get a legal memory
address I still get a legal memory
address that's
weird really
it okay I'm very confused as to how this
can actually be
being wrong at this
point I'm set it to I'm just going
to make absolutely sure that it's not an
off by one or two I don't think this
should be minus two
here to be clear
okay yeah
no python hasn't rotted my brain right
this Loops to
than num
steps minus 2
fiddling there's not a good way of
debugging this as far as I'm
why not call comment all all the array
assignments to be fair I did
uh I did
something before but yeah that would be
a really good way of narrowing it
down I'm kind of just getting stupid
yeah oh missed
one cuz I don't even know where like I
don't even have any idea where this is
it's really annoying that you can't just
like set a flag to uh get the to get
memory sanitizer
working the
heck now it fails to
yeah this works we should just be able
to binary search it
right I hate having to debug code this
way though it's like so incredibly
boring I just lose all
Focus as long as I have a working
debugger I can usually make progress
very very
quickly this type of [ __ ] is just really
annoying particularly because this
worked on my uh this worked on the
test okay so this doesn't fail
at
least without the thing is the score
distribution changes as well
see yeah we'll just take a few minutes
binary search
oops Yeah it's
painful I mean I genuinely really enjoy
my work when it's not like this
right because as long as I have the
feedback loop I can build stuff very
very quickly
okay legal memory
access when you have this on
so is the bug on the T index then if the
idx index is correct
oh hang
on t +
1 how do you do
this t+
one
i+ J
do I just have this index totally
wrong I times
so it's this T it's the t+ one index
that's out of bounds but how's that out
of
Bounce I +
J + 1
index I mean that's just giving you the
offset that it processes
right that it uh that it
processes thread
index hold on what if so if k equals
zero
is there like an edge
case on the very last
no I actually don't know what's wrong
with that index for
that uh it'll hang on compiler might
optimize that
did this
break yeah that's
broke there what's the plan for neural
MMO still think it's the best way well
have you seen
3 I built this in uh I built this over
the
summer so this
is pretty much everything I did during
my PhD on nural MMO except it looks
better and it runs a thousand times
faster uh and it has actually has a few
additional tricky bits fixed as well and
this is I
mean it's bigger this is actually even
not the fullsize map this is just what
we run on the web
version more agents
so yeah there's more there is a lot of
stuff for neural MMO going forward um
and in fact it's going to be a core end
in a lot of the research that we're
doing it's just that there's so many
things that are broken with
reinforcement learning that you know the
thing of puffer is more General it's we
got to fix reinforcement learning like I
started neural MMO as a project of like
how do we push reinforcement learning to
really solve long-term challenges in Ai
and then it's like you know we fell off
the bike and broke both our legs because
we had like nobody's ever solved any of
the really really basic obvious stuff
haven't seen this actually it's awesome
it's all open source and in fact it's
like a third of the length of the code
AS nuro 2 is as
well it was the first thing I wrote in
see so there are a couple little things
on this that are weird but um yeah 2800
some odd lines it's all right here this
one file I think a first year under rad
could throw could uh scroll through this
and read it as well it's very very
simple code with the exception of a
couple PCG algorithms and then the uh
the way I select tiles for rendering is
a little janky but everything else is
pretty
simple I mean we have more than just
this as well right we've got like
miniature version of open ai5 here now I
can play this and uh where is like
something oops am I holding the wrong
key
yeah I'm holding the wrong key but
anyways you can play around with some of
those on the
do okay so we still get an illegal
memory access
the uh the model the model on the
website is not great but it is kind of a
cool demo in the sense that I trained
the model for over 2,000 years of
gameplay and you can just do that now
because it runs so fast
definitely going to take a look at those
seen the mooba but somehow missed nurl
Mo 3 there's a blog post as well on
it I think it's just on my
X that's the big
world item
combat and
progression trading economy there's a
baseline
stuff aha this fixes it so the question
is why is T this big
and we'll have to fix something with
that because that'll change something
else but we'll
see it's so fiddly that you can't like
catch
that funny thing is I could make neural
MMO so much better you know going
forward as
well it really was just like I just
started coding that thing like manic
just manic coding in scyon and like I
made a whole bunch of dumb design
decisions because I was using scyon
instead of C from the start and then I
just basically did a one toone port into
C and cleaned it up a little bit um so
yeah I could probably make it even
better
it's not the type of thing where I think
that the best use of my time is to just
always work on neural MMO and nothing
else right there's like poor stuff in RL
to fix that is I mean you can fix it on
much simpler M's and then have it work
on neural MMO and more complex M but I
think it is going to be a project that I
keep coming back to is like you know the
hard M to test
there we
go see if this still works
sorry for the interrupt the
interrogation now you're
got super bogged down with this let's
see if it works
still fascinated by a complex
environments that potentially approach
open-endedness yeah and I mean we've had
a few good candidates but the main
problems have been infra like net hack
for instance net hack is really awesome
it is single agent which is a little
limiting but um it's like a really
really hard M well the problem with it
is the python wrappers are kind of slow
and uh the environment itself apparently
you can't run multiple copies per
process there's like an issue with uh
threading it I mean not threading it
there's like an issue with it having
global uh Global variables or whatever
so you can't batch it in the way that
you'd actually want for RL and like I
mean the number of people that
understand
like that is an issue um and like that
is the main thing holding it back is
single digit to non-existent right like
people just see environment they see oh
it looks hard they see oh people didn't
make much progress on it RL must not
just work very well right they don't see
like well it's mostly researchers with
tiny Hardware budgets and the m is just
running too slow because of these
constraints right
so that's what we're trying to
fix this got way farther though didn't
it no it only got to 10
mil it's
weird all I video explains that yeah oh
I guess more than zero people know that
now with the
video
um but the thing that's just so sad
about this is like I really didn't have
to bust out anything too crazy uh to
make this work right like it's not like
I have some fancy new simd architecture
for specifically for rlms like no I just
wrote really really basic simple C
that's all I
did I just wrote not Python and like not
stupid that's
okay this is going to drive me nuts
um how is this still
you going a t of topic so I have more to
read on today what are your general
thoughts on volunteer computing
applied to these
environments
um volunteer I mean generally the way it
works at the moment is like the M's are
fast enough that if you have a decent
desktop you can do some research with us
and uh if you are a prominent
contributor then I get you Hardware
access
anyways um we don't have a ton at the
moment we just have like a a very small
cluster but we do have plans and funds
to get a 40 node a 40 node cluster so we
can be farming out more resources to
contributors that's really the plan here
and I mean we have this at the moment so
we're going to end up with 40 of these
and we have a new facility that's going
to be able to take care of these and uh
you know I'll have some of those boxes
for myself I'll allocate a bunch of them
to open source contributors and then we
will use some of them them for uh work
done for
clients that's the current plan
um I don't know if it's the same type of
problem where it just automatically
scales that well it's it's more like we
run batches of like a couple hundred
experiments at a
time I think we're going to be okay on
compute is the thing because like unless
something changes our stuff just runs
fast enough that I can just have the
compute cluster for this and just make
it easy
right like I think we only need on the
order of like a few hundred,
worth of compute so I can just do that
and then that's just taken care
do that
works I wonder if this will do it
I don't know I'm kind of getting tired
of debugging stupid indexing bugs
maybe if it gets to the end here is
that this the problem
one this Loops Horizon
times I think maybe I just overcount by
one so all the indexing wasn't mattering
because I just overcounted the uh K was
one too large no still no screw
you really
no this should be fine as
well this should literally be
fine this is the type of [ __ ] I hate
doing cuz it's like I could be getting
so much stuff
the largest that this can
get is Horizon minus one right
31 okay
plus
32 that seems
bad
might have time to look at solving this
I'm hoping I solved this before today I
mean that would be ridiculous if
not I'm kind of just trying stuff at
this point
any interest in that is that too deep in
the code
base uh I mean if you have Cuda
experience you're welcome to but like
this is this is like one silly little
fiddly kernel in um a new algorithm that
doesn't make much sense yet
so yeah uh let me finish probably like
probably let me finish this I think
we're probably going to start doing some
some more Cuda somewhat soon but then
there also there's like there's tons of
cool stuff on the environment side and
uh for people with more research
background there's like there's tons of
science side stuff um there's tons of
experiment side stuff there just lots
and lots and lots of things to do in
puffer right
yeah this
yay okay so it doesn't
train but we will look at
here's your reward of
one 6
seven six perfect cuz it's so it's six
before
this and you get
your uh your
different yeah the value standard
deviations are different
right well they're not really though
they're very
close so why would this happen then
gamma is divided
by gamma
it's more confident towards the end well
that's
weird that could just be some drift
though it does seem pretty
consistent oh you know what this is I
think this is just my
initialization okay
one oh and this doesn't make sense
either right
DS oh it just printed
weird yeah no this is
correct that it has this
and why is this value so
me maybe it's because of this reward
standard deviation that's being
subtracted
we don't really know if this is a good
thing to do anymore do we
okay we'll see if that runs I'll be
right
well hello
there um that's a result it
trains it suddenly actually
trains cool
well this is back to like a reasonable
level of progress wouldn't you say we
have an algorithm it
trains things are good life is
good let's do that again with advantage
normalization on
we'll wait this one out and then we'll
see but uh I mean this is kind of great
I can
just we'll get rid of
this
this R of this
it's initialization here can I delete
this and have it still
work or just break
well and then the only other thing I
want to know is
the fact that those last two are ones is
also a
problem just had a
woodpecker jump into my window
off Florida's pretty
funny we've got to get big woodpeckers
yeah I think um
it's backwards because we're not
bootstrapping the confidence
maybe this does make
sense I'll just have to think about it
and I'll look at the PO paper for a bit
I
funny what did I do
wrong oh that make
this is like a TD residual right where
is this
approximation yeah so here we
have oh but you're supposed to use the
last gamma
I think here you can
do you can do K
next see what I
broke H gamma is buff
this is all stuff that we're going to be
able to test in the uh the C
file did that fix it
it did fix
it well that's
great I believe it fixed it
yeah oh now it's
reversing or just
e this is
also is this how you boot drop this let
me
it's got to be just not doing the
bootstrapping correctly right
I gotta run soon as well a
meeting but we will see if we can get a
little bit of
progress okay so what's happened here
it's changed
right I think it
changed for
would you be
willing do review is the only thing left
is the building popper yeah of
course to have time tomorrow for review
okay yeah let's do that that sounds
great
[Music]
you'll be able to get neural networking
awesome I will get some good rest and
make sure I'm well ready to do that
okay I'm going to run these last couple
of tests real
quick three two
huh second to last
one so
I'll just run this real quick through
perer and then I'll commit this stuff up
in whatever the current state
okay cool that looks like a value
bootstrap gone probably wrong but that's
something for
sure well we'll go from there um I will
I had to go get ready for a meeting and
then I may be back we'll
see get some exercise and stuff in as
well but uh for the couple folks still
watching all my stuff's at puffer doai
want to support the project for free
start the GitHub join on Discord if
you're interested in getting involved
and follow on X for more thank you and